hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the possession experiment
a game word you have to take control of
other people and decide their lives and
their fates for them in order for you to
survive that's all I know about the game
because I only read the synopsis but
that is the game game settings movement
tank ready weapon hold what I don't even
know what those are refering what do
they move like a tank I know I'm built
like a tank but do I need to move like a
tank or whatever let's begin this
apparently this game has multiple
endings too so depending on how
captivating the game is I may have to
play it again to get the other endings
you are a scientist with dem Corp an
organization dedicated to experimenting
with the paranormal you work in base 75
their top secret underground bunker
testing human possession one day an
entity has escaped containment the
normal safety measure a device referred
to as an EMP device is not functioning
the facility is in lockdown most of the
staff is dead and you're stuck in the
control room with no connection to the
outside world you must get out fix the
EMP device neutralize the entity and get
to the elevator before the EMP dice runs
out of power you're stuck in the control
room so you must use the subjects of
your possession experiment to escape
nice to look around but the monitor
press space to examine oh we love that
no silliness here the game has no
checkpoints or save systems if a test
subject gets killed they are dead for
good if all three die then it's game
over
some items are randomly located between
playthroughs zoom in the map to see
camera names and locations came room
numbers on the map will glitch when the
entity has since said room each test
subject can only carry three inventory
items one weapon at the time weapons
can't kill the entity been dealing
enough damage will ward off for a while
be able to control people with a
computer what once was a power only the
dead can possess is now a power the
Living can have thanks to the power at
dem core alright okay emergency an
entity has escaped its containment and
killed the entire staff the base is in
lockdown I can't access the elevator the
EMP device didn't neutralize the entity
allowing the staff to escape it
overloaded and broke down it needs to be
fixed but I can't leave my location or
I'll get killed where are you located in
the
control room the room doesn't have
proper ventilation so the enemy can't
get in at least for now what about the
experiment what are the current results
of the project as the entity infected it
the results of controlling people
through a computer have been positive
the entity hasn't messed up with the
project or our test subjects yet sorry
but we decided not to provide any
assistance and in a few days we'll send
someone to retrieve the experiment and
try to contain the enemy you can't be
serious
this chat is over and we're locking you
out from communicating with the outside
world
all right what a bunch of dicks Arlis
dudas possessing subjects 1 2 & 4
possessed subject status set to left
monitor map information right camera
says whoa hi Oh oh my god I am
controlling this man pistol ammo
obtained ok hang on let me oh ok
am pzw BSA weird oh this is so weird
this is so bizarre that's crazy
oh hi Oh got a knife okay that's good
this is so weird
oh wow it's kinda like a five nights at
Freddy's thing but also completely
different it's only in that way because
it's just like you're standing around in
a room controlling monitors but yeah
this is completely different in past
studies we have discovered that entities
take on two different forms one being a
gas like form and the other being a more
solid form and they can switch between
the two forms of will of course both
forms contain their advantages and
disadvantages in its gas like form
entities are almost completely invisible
and they can pretty much travel through
small areas such as vents or pipe
systems during this form entities can't
be harmed but at the same time they
can't harm us also their interactions
with the physical objects are very small
basically any object that can be
affected by a gust of wind in his solid
like form entities are unable to travel
through small spaces however in a solid
form entities are more than capable of
causing physical harm to us and they
have more interactions with physical
objects yet despite these entities can
harmed as well in this form while
entities cannot be killed they still
retain some animal instinct when it
comes danger if the enemy gets harmed
enough enough to kill a living human the
entity will instantly change to its
gas-like form and leave the area
however the entity will eventually
change back to its solid form and
continue what it was originally doing so
even though you can't kill an ende the
fact of the matter is running away from
it isn't the only option so if you're in
a situation where you're confronted by
an Indian or drun grab a weapon and
fight back it can be enough to warn the
entity off and give you enough time to
get away
weird okay shotgun ammo obtained well
got a lot of ammo here but I don't know
how that's gonna do for me or if that is
gonna do anything for me that inventory
full okay well that's good I guess
pistol ammo okay more pistol ammo so
there's plenty of pistol ammo ah EMP
device oh this is the EMP device despite
a same EMP device doesn't emit the same
kind of electromagnetic pulse that can
fry electronics rather it emits the
electric pulse in a way that won't
affect electronics but will affect
electrons is that supernatural entities
are composed of leading to them being
them unstable and incapable of forming
physical form
well the EMP device is connected to a
control panel the device requires a
second source of power to work past
sophistical II a car battery the reason
for this is because electric pulse that
the device emits can travel through
power cables and can lead to serious
malfunctions with the Bunker's
electronic devices leaving shut down
okay so it's damaged cable needs to be
fixed and it's missing a battery okay
he's a bypass key okay so we need a
battery we need cable and we need a
bypass key you need an access card for
that oh my god so how will I know when
an entity's chasing me down okay he's in
room 13 that's this long hallway here
I'm guessing CR is the control room whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa I didn't
know that whoa whoa whoa you tall
bastard you get away from me
you'll get away from me you freak freak
always this is this here oh oh oh
imma imma fight back yah yah yah yah
Oh oh that ain't good oh oh that ain't
good
oh that ain't good time to get up and
out of ze w ZW in the house was it Oh
God
okay so there's a little shimmer where
he is oh seven is shimmering right now
and shaken ah that's too weird
oh this is bizarre god these peoples
live long I will give me give me give me
give me I got a nice you're gonna get it
come on come at me I'm going in here
where am i where am i r3
where's our three r3 s OE z get some get
some get some get some ooh he did it he
did it ZW is a champion oh god yes Oh
drop it
Oh gotta hit tab okay what is uh how do
i oh no this is BSA how do they get to
PSA okay BSA so BS badass but I need to
get I I know I drop are okay
drop that okay P oh stop give me the
pure stock got the pure still look if
there's a first-aid kit here use okay
he's good
okay he's better up now we need to give
some pistol ammo I know that there's
plenty of it I just need to go find it
it's another Oh piss lame-o okay can I
reload reloading pistol okay we're good
yeah lordy Lou there's some shotgun
shells a first aid kit probably
important yeah okay this way okay this
way whoa hey you're up and Adam go go go
go go is that a keycard I'm gonna get
you boom oh yeah get out here yeah GW is
up badass or BSA sorry room six key Oh
God stop hitting tab you [ __ ] who is
me I'm gonna drop the shotgun ammo for
now I need to reload no no no I need to
reload the pistol did I really use all
eight bullets geez
no not that [ __ ] okay I'm gonna drop the
shotgun ammo right not tap space okay
you're gonna go here you're gonna grab
this okay room six key where's room six
room six is oh [ __ ] he's on the way uh
okay I'm gonna go this way I'm gonna go
around well that's not a good thing well
that's not a good thing well that's not
a good thing well that's not a good
thing but it go around
ring-around-the-rosy
sorry I don't know why that spooked me
like that that really shouldn't have
that was not even remotely that scary
this is not room six where's room six
okay here this what excuse me you want
to run that by me again okay that was
only four shots those four shots Oh God
there was six shots apparently why was
that six I don't know it needs an ask
ass-kicking it needs an ass-kicking okay
use that it's open what's in room six
what do we got room 15 okay that's good
locked case corrosive to break the latch
Wow Wow
well okay I do not have enough bullets
at the MoMA I could use a shotgun that
would be sick nasty what is this by the
way Oh Zoey winners Oh massive infection
of mold
wait ZEW Bob wait wait what [ __ ]
god no go go now run run you [ __ ]
okay uh uh oh this is a dead end isn't
it oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god
okay where is he okay he's I've lost him
I've done it I'm a genius I have lost
him forever and ever I have lost him
I'll get the hang of this layout
sometime soon okay we need we're gonna
use this okay that's great
can take that we're gonna use that I'm
getting used to this interface little
funkalicious where am I room 16 okay
room 15 is right next to it can I have
that room 15 okay go down here use that
go in here go in here all right good
we're in here now which is great I love
this this is a great place to be what is
this this looks fun from 8ki even good
yet good very good
is that a corrosive acid chem s8h that
sounds pretty corrosive to me pistol
ammo you know it baby okay I'm gonna
drop the shotgun ammo I'm gonna pick up
this corrosive I think this looks like a
corrosive thing okay is this a report
the test yeah capable of mask is that
controlling the subjects with chemicals
some of the chemistry mixture will
creates a fuse that can be painful here
today when contact the other mixtures
can be very toxic at that subject is too
delicate but the chemicals show no
irritation completely overpower the mask
man with mask Momo we begin the
experiment we came across a malfunction
with the mask we commanded the subject
to twist his wrist pour chemical but
instead the subject twist his necks 180
degrees snapping a neck and killing the
subject subject started fine at first
but inward experiments sceptic began to
form strong tears in the eyes assume
this updos hands started to shake we
decided an experiment hsj with mask 1.1
subject was completely powerless at
first from masks but as soon as we had
the subject mixing more dangerous
chemicals the subject began to shape and
drop 1 the camels will lead into
creating very importance fumes
experiment is very successful subject
before in a very chemical mixture
without issues okay so these masks are
what are controlling these people is
what I'm getting ok 16 8 8 8 8 IC 8 ok
nope nope I see 8 ok we're good we're
good this way and where was 8 was this
whoa where am i where am i where am i
where am i no no no no no room 11
whoa hi how you doing you got a mask on
that's dad it's odd yeah that's very odd
okay back up one I kept one look at this
one roommate okay right Oh a roommate
got that in here roommate this looks fun
pistol ammo okay got that I got a lot of
pistol a about this time around
electrical tape electrical tape I could
probably use that too I've got too much
pistol ammo I don't need that no I need
the electrical tape not the pistol ammo
oh god I dropped it yeah in a bad place
Oh what did I just do wait what did I
get what I needed I got that is where
the corrosive was supposed to be right
chemical chemical chemical chemical
right here right here yeah yeah yeah use
that oh one of two ingredients to make a
corrosive I don't have the other
ingredient well I'll drop this one right
here then drop okay that's good it's
fine this is this is fascinating is so
weird so bizarre
okay I don't remember where the place
was that I was supposed to go was this
room 11 12 key okay I can pick that up
room 11 12 that's right over here what
is this oh oh oh I see you I see you
gonna die I'm gonna go around I'm gonna
go around I'll go around I know this
place now my sense of direction is
impeccable and you can't be me hey
stupid
room 12 yeah go get use you use you okay
want pistol ammo but I don't need that
definitely don't need that uh this looks
like a place for another chemical to be
not seeing anything
where's this other chemical oh there we
go mixing equipment well I don't have
chemicals alright uh we got a chemical
book okay
blend chemical s8h chemical r7e basic
equipment to uses okay that sounds good
where is this other chemical first aid
kit that's helpful
ah God room 17 key oh god I'll leave
this here then where's room 17 okay down
there
but where's this goddamn other chemical
what what happened what was that what
just happened what just happened
I don't know what just happened okay
hear that oh hi
okay did my glass like disappear or
something why can I hear really good now
Wow
oh god no not like you're gonna go down
buddy it does so many more bullets than
it I think it does I shouldn't waste
that though uh it's down here and then
to the left yeah this is it god I'm
going in so many of these rooms okay
what do we have what do we have what do
we have this game is really cool by the
way I I really do kind of like this it's
it's very different but also it's
reminiscent like old school games which
like Resident Evil the the first ones
which I never really played but you know
oh [ __ ] wrong way here yes I left the
chemical here oh that was something
going across might I hit tab again why
do I keep doing that
I keep thinking inventory is tab but
it's not it's completely different it's
not a different screen okay I need to
drop this for now I need to pick up can
this I need to go the other side to mix
the chemicals to do the corrosive to
open the case to whatever
I don't even know what's in the case but
I gotta go here to here here buddy here
buddy and there it is and we're gonna
put there we go
in right oh god no do that be you [ __ ]
okay that's way too many bullets oh
lordy Lou did I get okay I've got one
corrosive more ammo I think I'm probably
hurt now okay okay we're good we got two
corrosives I only know what to do with
one of them but I'm gonna go do that
here we go locked case corrosive Wow why
there you [ __ ] you douche bypass key
Oh for the the thing the thing with the
thing okay
I need to be here is the thing okay
I hit it four times okay it takes four
shots maybe even three to get rid of
them electrical tape
okay I'm gonna draw actually no I'm not
gonna drop I think it's right you know
these are the bathrooms Oh No thank you
EMP is in sixteen that's right EMP is in
16 16
no this is 15 16 would be right here
whoa why three okay he got hurt but
that's okay he's he's so tough he's so
tough I just dropped that wide yeah
there we go
okay so the bypass key is there I need
to get electrical tape and then a
battery the electrical tape I dropped
back in the room I was just in which was
over here right there how bad he's okay
well one more hit and he's probably
electrical tape is good oh he just went
by my window I saw that I saw that buddy
how you doing pal get wrong item how
about EMP device here okay tape has been
used now we just need a battery I think
that's the only thing that we need oh
I'm trying to Rack my brain as to what
I've forgotten what is this room 18 key
where's room 18
18s big over there this way the way the
cameras turn I'm trying to Rack my brain
and try to like get this all sorted but
it is slightly confusing most of the
time okay this is promising dead by oh
that's a good pub three bullets even
though I used
five okay what do we have here the
current PC mass prototype hasn't been
showing improvements over the past
iterations past side effects such as
increased panic levels tearing up the
eyes twitches and mumbling and made no
appearance we're unsure if the subject
is aware of being possessed but it's
irrelevant what matters is that the
subject is unable to resist the
influence of the PC mask we really
wanted to install head mounted cameras
but it has become an issue due to the
high levels of supernatural energy that
the PC masks emit the footage becomes
completely corrupted also while the
supernatural energy is not usually
strong enough to affect our security
cameras whenever subjective receipts any
sort of serious damage or gets killed a
large store - vendor who shoots out
causing slight corruption - security
cameras lastly so far the masks can stay
connected with the control center within
the bunker banannie for the connection
breaks and the subject become
unpossessed we also had a casualty when
we tried to send a subject out for field
testing and attacked a staff member in
the elevator luckily security shot the
subject before to harm to anyone though
we are now down another test subject
interesting first aid kit also very
interesting okay I just can't panic
shoot that's the thing what is this what
is this entity seven was found
possessing a young girl in a home
located in redacted the girl was found
restrained to her bed with the bodies of
what appeared to be your family and an
exorcist lying next to her after
reincarnating the girl's body we were
properly able to contain the entity for
testing and experimentation ok
reincarnating sure the entity was a tall
thin decaying humanoid wearing a pair of
old jeans and boots and what appears to
be a mask made of porcelain that is in
good condition compared to the rest of
the entity the current origins of this
entity remain unknown but current
evidence and research has suggested this
entity has appeared for around 70 years
and appears to be the cause of at least
21 possessions while most possessions
have led to the victim getting killed
within a few weeks obsession some of its
victims have survived
survivors have reported that before the
entity possesses you it will remove its
mask revealing its decaying face the
entity that places the mask over the
victims face leading them to be
possessed by the entity interesting
where is this mysterious shotgun they
keep giving me ammo for I have no idea
and also what else was in this room this
can't be the only thing that was here
why
hey bud hey buddy boo okay ah God where
do I go this is chemical book but I
already got the camels I've got one more
corrosive but I just don't know what to
do with it okay let me let me scoot
around this way I'm gonna try to avoid
him if he's coming this way I hope he
can't do anything to me because dad dad
that wouldn't be good
Oh what is this have I been here
corrosive to brake the latch to get a
shoddy gun oh my god battery even better
even better than the shotgun not by much
mind you but it's okay needs a battery
so battery leave the control room by
looking at the door impressing ass
Oh Oh God
I didn't even think about it oh my god I
didn't even think about it oh my god I
didn't even think holy crap I didn't
even think about it I didn't even think
about the people I was possessing I'm an
[ __ ] I didn't even think I didn't
even hesitate oh my god
that came so cool I really legitimately
enjoyed that I had fun with that that
was that was like a different control
scheme than what I was used to it was
like different ideas that I was used to
and god I did not even think about that
oh my god okay I am gonna play this
again I want to get to another ending I
want to do the ending where I save
everyone I I think I would know how
right you know I think I know how okay
let's do this
okay okay okay okay all right let's do
this we don't need anything pistol ammo
we'll need was here what do you have oh
he doesn't have anything oh my god is it
random did they change where things were
oh my god they did didn't they
oh those [ __ ] oh no they did oh it's
random
oh it's random oh god oh no oh no it's
random oh no I don't even remember where
I got the pistol from okay uh no no this
way is room 18 which I just got the key
for there's more pistol how much pistol
ammo do I need the answer is a lot but
get room 18 okay got that I'm full up on
pistol and like it's so much pistol and
I'm slammed with pistol ammo so girthy
with this here's more pistol ammo I'm
just I'm fold to the brim I'm folding it
ticks with pistol ammo nothing but
shotgun ammo to John you know you love
it
I'll drop this off in the room where the
shotgun spawns just in case I want it
god
that's there in case I want that which I
know I will someday but now is not that
date where am I gonna go I need a pistol
I need a pistol bad
no not in here this is a stupid place to
be restroom we got a first-aid kit
that's useful no pistol here God there
was a pistol here before wasn't there
room 11 12 key I like the sound of that
I like the sound of that where the hell
am I oh here I am okay more pistol ammo
yeah I love the sound of that I love
this sound okay what is this I'm six key
right there I don't need the first-aid
kit right now go okay but the first-aid
kit right here okay oh hey buddy how you
doing
owner of this Matt this mask has to have
something to do well hey buddy how are
you doing good to see you oh god oh god
oh god
this mask has to do something with this
creature right the masks that we have is
obviously related it's it's too similar
not to be related room 6 I thought I had
room 16 key didn't have room 11 12
where's room 6 room 8 what's room 6
where the hell is room 6 oh god yeah of
course of course of course wait no that
was the key right there it's on the oh
god I dropped that not that what what
did I what oh my god
okay here we go here we go here we can
be on it we got it we're good we're good
we're good we're good no panic no panic
needed no panic needed oh hey buddy I
see you up there first aid kit there's
so many first aid kits is swimming in
first aid kits who needs this many first
aid kits not me
definitely not me there's so many for C
kits why is for sick it's okay that was
not helpful that at all exactly no help
where's 6 ok I know where 6
wha-wha-what why oh god I didn't know I
didn't know I'm sorry I didn't know I
didn't know I didn't know why is this
such hell what is this
he's gonna die because I'm an idiot no
where's the first-aid kit when you need
it oh he's gonna die he's gonna die he's
gonna die for take it okay get out of
here get out of here get out of here you
suck ass okay uh use okay we're fine
we're good we're good now let's grab
this other one just in case get back to
room six okay we're good
what is this from 15 I love that I love
that and what's this one from seventeen
love that okay we can pro oh that's
creepy what are you okay yeah yeah yeah
I probably should have taken advantage
that moment of indecisiveness but I
didn't okay take that love that love
this love that there was nothing in the
bathrooms I know that I know that
there's nothing in the bathrooms okay
this way this way oh I'm sorry oh that's
what I hate it
okay I hate it oh god it's distracting
oh god this is bad
oh no no no not like this not like this
not like this no no no no no listen
listen listen you don't need to do this
you don't need to do this you're so slow
good good good you're slow okay good
thank you for returning to normal weird
freaky thing okay uh what is this room a
roommate I think I have that key no I do
not I was like the entire dad fifteen
seventeen fifteen seventeen fifteen
seventeen fifteen seventy where's
fifteen where's seventeen are they both
on the downswing I think they're both on
the down I think they're both down yeah
both down there there I have no gun I
can't believe I have no gun that's
ridiculous that I have no gun ah
experiment results not helpful at all
even even a little bit not at all
helpful damn gun room eight good do we
need a gun I need again so badly I need
a gun so badly I need a gun so nope this
there we go
s pistol ammo that's not a gun
okay well both chemicals would be here
room eight
where's roommate again okay room eight
okay no let me go unlock roommate oh my
god oh my god not like this not like
this not like this not like this not
like this not like this let me unlock
this real quick okay I gotta go I'm not
even gonna go in there I'm gonna grab a
med kit here we go wrap grab it grab it
grab it go go go Oh
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god I'm again using med
kit
can lock roommate it's gonna go grab the
other chemical real quick oh this is the
wrong way sorry excuse him Wow and to go
in here and to mix the chemicals come on
come on okay I'm gonna get the shotgun
if it's not gonna give me a pistol I am
going to have a shotgun cuz screw you
you [ __ ]
okay use a quick use a quick okay get it
get the shotgun no not the battery the
shotgun get that shotgun oh my god what
is wrong with you okay load shotgun I'm
going to blast you you are gonna get
blasted try me whatever your name is I
don't even know what was your name I
expend to t7 what a stupid name
what a big you heard me talking [ __ ]
what a stupid name either way I've got
the battery so let me go put the battery
in I got a big shotgun big beefy shotgun
okay batteries in there need to fix the
wire there was something else that I saw
I've got the corrosive for what's in the
case which I think is the override key I
swear that man is broken enough
more shotgun ammo yes please how many I
got oh so much oh my god so much okay I
need another corrosive okay got the
corrosive I'm gonna go melt the the
thing on the thing is this right weed is
that a pit is that the pistol oh my god
that's the pistol I walked right by
because I was in such a hurry
god dammit I'm an idiot it doesn't
matter use that what's in here bypass
key great love that I'm gonna leave that
on the ground next to the thing a woman
excellent shot okay I'm gonna leave this
right here no no no we're not changing
subjects just yet I will eventually but
I want this guy to go full hog before I
change subjects around it so the EMP is
now fixed it's ready to wrap that's the
storage room this is the lab I think
that's about it right that's it right
okay here's my plan
I'm gonna leave this dude right here
ready to rock any MIT can i what if this
guy I did this guy to shoot me is that
even possible
oh my god that's an experiment for next
time but I'm gonna have this guy right
here by the levator and I'm gonna go
grab another dude and I'm gonna come
back if zappy man comes near this one
okay so you're ze wo kzw it's your time
to shine up but I just need a well hey
bud didn't ski I guess I don't need to
worry about you being by the other dude
oh my god okay so you're gonna go get
the pistol okay you're right there which
is great very good you're gonna grab
pistol ammo which is fine I'm gonna go
over here to this door go in here the
pistol is right here okay
where's this dude okay he's in this
hallway I think Oh dick yep yep yep yep
yep okay three shots boom boom boom
took some damage missed okay all right
so now I got two right there I got my
two dudes right there now the last dude
is going to hit the button pick up the
key which I dropped hit the button we're
all gonna pile into this elevator and
then I'm gonna hit this door and we are
going to be out of there no problem okay
last dude what last subject he's gonna
hit the button he's gonna do the thing
he's gonna run back and then Wiis gonna
get out of here so oh my god why why why
why every goddamn time you're coming
after the ones that are doing the
important stuff I don't like that at all
okay good um good up guys okay this is a
test of this [ __ ] okay we're yeah oh
yeah oh yeah you didn't even stand a
chance now you're there you're gonna go
back we've got a little bit of time
before he Reema T realises we're gonna
slam this bypass key then we're gonna
run we've got 30 seconds we got 30
seconds let's go okay we're gonna go
we're going we're going you're gonna be
the first in first in first in okay come
on second in
third in all right and go
she did seem nude see dude oh wow you
were able to escape the facility along
with all three test subjects soon after
you escaped your report dem court and
yourself to the authorities for their
illegal experiments you don't know if
the test subjects you escaped with can
forgive you for what you did to them or
if they'll ever be able to recover you
wouldn't have blamed them if they had
killed you the moment they were free but
it seems they have decided to make you
live with what you have done that's
crazy that's so fun that is so fun that
is legitimately fun I like that but
there's six endings what are the other
things that you could do I got to try
one more thing this game is this games
nope
I love this this is so imaginative and
it's spooky in a way that like you
wouldn't really consider things to be
spooky you know what I mean
it's really cool I like it a lot I like
this a lot this is a really fun I just I
just have to try one more thing I don't
need a lot to get it I just want to go
like I just need a gun I think you might
you guys might know what I'm gonna try
to do but you'll be fun there we are
there we are okay so I need to drop this
grab of this okay I don't know what this
is gonna do if this is gonna do anything
it might do nothing might do something
all right let's get right about let's
get right point-blank on this right uh
come on can I commit there we go oh yeah
that's a good look ah really
ah go in here it's locked
why why is it locked oh well that's
stupid wait what happens if I okay this
is a this is kind of malicious but I'm
kind of curious to what happens I mean I
can guess okay yeah that that that makes
that makes sense yeah that that makes
perfect sense what happens when all the
subjects die is the question god can you
imagine just being fully aware but mine
controlled to the point where you didn't
know or wasn't able to stop yourself oh
hey bud
what the hell you all right oh no did he
you bugged out uh whatever
oh oh hey oh well that's uh yeah that's
um that makes sense that makes sense
that makes perfect sense that makes
sense is that one was what that would
happen to that makes total sense alright
I've got one more thing I want to try
what oh oh oh that that alright
Oh hate hate that or if I can squeeze a
bullet through there ah okay so what am
I do this guy it's a noble sacrifice
type of deal what's gonna happen is I'm
gonna let them all go they're all gonna
go they're gonna skedaddle out of here
they're gonna be ready to go and then
last but not least we're gonna smash the
alarm
Rizzy yeah we're fine we're fine we're
good we're good we're practically great
actually oh not so great that's not is
what I was hoping it would be oh [ __ ] I
don't like that alright we need to go to
you god okay he's gonna slam the alarm
and then they're all gonna dog pile in
the elevator and frankly I am gonna stay
behind because I I've done some bad
things I've done bad things maybe I
don't deserve to escape god that's a
tight window okay cover the door cover
the door go without me you all deserve
to live you all deserve to live it's
good seeing you instead of leaving
you've spent the little time you add to
get all the test subjects to the
elevator and escape by the time the
elevator reaches the surface to control
the masks and your experiment will have
worn off it's unclear what the future
holds for them but at least they are
free from what you have put them through
perhaps they can take comfort in knowing
that you died with your experiment but
that's only three of the well that's
four of the six endings pod now I'm
curious like what what would it take I'm
actually quite curious now what are all
the possible endings so the other
endings are not amazing I
like if you get one subject out and if
you get two subjects out those are the
different endings so I got all the
endings that are like actually different
so that was good I liked that a lot it
was a new take on or but also it just
had this nice feel to it like the the
observational voyeuristic aspect of it
and the the bizarre knowledge of knowing
that you are controlling humans and
their lives are in your hands and maybe
they're aware of it the whole time but
they can't do a damn thing that idea is
just horrifying
oh that's awful a great game I really
like that there's a lot of potential in
this I think this is just a really cool
idea
very very cool that was the possession
experiment thank you everybody so much
for watching if you want to support the
developer Alex alinka vich is the name
of them they've got a patreon make more
stuff like this this is so cool you
could expand this so far this idea could
go so far I love it I love this and I
love what you've got going on so keep it
up so thank you everybody someone for
watching everything is linked in the
description below if you want to play to
the other endings if you want to see
Alex alinka vich check it out in the
description below thank you everybody
again and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye
[Music]